so first let's talk about nuclear
propulsion so out there interesting
propulsion ideas uh so what do you think
beyond the the chemical engines that we
talked about what do you think about
using nuclear
fission and maybe even nuclear fusion
for uh for propulsion we already have
thermal nuclear reactors uh they're
nuclear engines that have been tested
both by the United States and Soviet
Union that were 100 valid like totally
ready to go efficient super awesome
um yes yes yes hardcore yes and what
what they're using is yeah basically a
fusion reactor you're flowing hydrogen
through it and heating up the hydrogen
taking it from liquid to a gas you know
and by heating it up you're you're
adding energy to the propellant and then
you're literally just using that now
steam hot hydrogen and flowing it
through a d level nozzle and you also
have to use that that energy to spin the
pumps to still pump the thing so you're
still kind of using like a lot of the
tricks you're using but instead of a
chemical reaction you're literally just
using
nuclear fission to heat up propellant
and do the same thing and at the end of
the day you end up with like eight to
nine hundred seconds of specific impulse
which is double that of chemical
propulsion most of that comes just
because hydrogen is so light you're only
emitting you're only ejecting hydrogen
out of the nozzle so the lighter
molecule is the faster you know just
like if you had a
you know a golf ball versus like a
bowling ball you can only physically
throw one so fast and the other one as a
human you're not going to do very well
with so you can just you get you have
the more potential for a higher exit
velocity so nuclear thermal amazing you
can just shoot these little hydrogen
molecules out crazy fast crazy
efficiently we already have it like we
can do it yes yes yes and actually we're
already re uh investing in that again as
United States is is looking at a
basically ramping back up our nuclear
propulsion why haven't we done it yet
and uh what do you think the challenges
are there and do you think that's an
obvious future like would you would you
see in 50 years we're not using
um
like we're not you for major projects
like a Starship type of project we're
not using chemical propulsion anymore
for getting off Earth you'll always want
to use chemical propulsion because the
the gas will become irradiated like you
don't but you don't want to and and
actually the Thruster weight ratio of
these engines are relatively poor
they're they're very heavy they have a
nuclear reactor like they're not they're
really the reason we kind of give up on
them is they're really most useful for
like interplanetary if you're trying to
get a big like if you're trying to send
a huge payload off to Mars nuclear
thermal is amazing
it's still could be beneficial even
going to the Moon you know like in an
Earth Moon system you could use nuclear
thermal uh very effectively it could be
a great choice but it also that starts
to get into that trait of like well we
can just kind of use a little bit bigger
rocket and
and fly a normal you know it's that
whole trade thing but another reason why
we kind of stopped using them the one
that the United States developed nerva
was so heavy only a Saturn V could
actually lift the stage of it like the
upper stage so replace the s4b with a
nuclear thermal with the nerva engine
um the Soviet Union developed one about
one tenth the size and and thrust that
was small enough to fly on Pro on a
proton rocket
um but neither of them ever flew both of
them have been tested and like thumbs up
ready to go which is just a huge shame
to me because they could unlock a lot of
interplanetary potential and yeah just
all around which potentially
Interstellar as well not I don't think
nuclear thermal not we're not quite
getting there but then you get into like
nuclear pulse drives and things where
you're literally like
basically ejecting a bomb out the back
of your rocket and exploding and having
like a shock absorber and pogo sticking
your way out of the solar system
that that's I mean by all physics sure
you know there's not nothing wrong with
that it's not breaking any laws of
physics and
you know I but I just don't see us
getting to that need anytime soon I
don't think we can still travel yeah I
mean that's that's I think we're going
to want a better understanding of
physics and physics itself yeah do you
have a hope that maybe theoretical
physics will open the door to some
exciting propulsional systems yeah
I do I think we're still at the very
infancy of our understanding of
everything and how things work and you
know 100 years ago it would be stupid to
try to predict the things we know today
and who knows like even you know I think
about things like James Webb looking
deeper into our solar system than ever
before and physically being able to see
objects that we just have not even been
able to physically see before on being
able to study black holes for example uh
a better better this stuff that's
happening outside of black holes at the
edges of black holes how the information
is stored uh the uh
holographic principles just there's so
much weirdness black holes yes around
where gravity starts bending light
it's like all right we'll get to look at
that now and start to wonder like what
is going on and how can we like use that
somehow except for propulsion I mean it
seems like awfully crazy and futuristic
at this moment but I think that's
because we know almost nothing about uh
you know that those kinds of objects
where again where the general relativity
and quantum mechanics start to start to
um have to be both considered to
describe those kinds of objects and as
we study those objects we might figure
out some kind of unification thing that
will allow us to uh understand maybe how
to use black holes to for propulsion
like yeah to uh I could say a lot of
crazy things but like basically but the
point is it'd be stupid for us to even
guess about things we don't even know
about yet you know what I mean like and
so therefore I'm not going to say that
the best option for Interstellar travel
is
nuclear drives like that could be like
someone saying you know in 1600 the only
way to fly is by strapping a thousand
Birds to your head you know like but
that said I mean everything you're
saying is right but the human history is
such like at the beginning of the 20th
century this is Rutherford they
everybody this This brilliant people
that said we've basically solved all of
it right if you talk to most physicists
I think they're going to say like we've
pretty much
solved like the standard model describes
physics extremely accurately right uh
general relativity explains the cosmos
as we observe them extremely accurately
yeah there's a whole Dark Matter Dark
Energy things whatever yeah but uh
outside of that so like we basically
solved like
like where are you going to find gaps in
knowledge that are going to somehow
create warp drives or something like
right so wormholes uh but uh that's it
seems like throughout history we prove
ourselves wrong time and time again yes
no I and I this is well outside of any
of my knowledge base so I want to make
sure that if I say anything stupid it's
because I'm I just a peasant here in
physics land but yes
um we're all peasants in physics land
but I really just think like it's very
humbling that we're still using chemical
propulsion and and variance out like
injecting mass to to propel ourselves
and I I and no matter how you get at it
and I think someday I I would expect
that our species has figured out a way
to get beyond that